ich merke gerade du nutzt mich gerade
nur aus zum Rühren Alter
boah ich bin eine Maschine ne nur so
lange rühren bis es notwendig ist nicht
überrüen ach so ah nee das war nicht gut
hallo meine Lieben hallo du musst wir
sind fusioniert du musst das so machen
Fusion ist so Fusion okay also wir
machen heute zusammen einen Apfelkuchen
vom Blech auf die ganz ganz einfache Art
und ich wollte euch mit diesem Video
zeigen dass ihr auch mal eure Partner
motivieren können einfach mal
mitzumachen gemeinsam backen ist schön
das ich f mich gerade wie ein Kind so
als erstes werden die Eier einmal
aufgeschlagen und hier reingetan kennst
du diesen Trend W machen na mag ich gar
nicht die armen Kinder komm jeder eins
die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen
übrigens immer in der Infobox K waschen
ja immer nach dem Eier aufschlagen man
ein so die Spitzen von den Händen
waschen warum musst du das denn machen
ja das ist so muss mir nachmachen oder
was so jetzt kommen alle flüssigen
Zutaten in die Schüssel boah das sind
richtig krasse Eier man sieht das
ehrlich rtig bioeer ja die sind echt Bio
nur Bio ich würde euch auch raten immer
nur Eier von
Null bi so da gebe ich jetzt Milch und
neutrales Öl mit dazu h du kannst dann
schon mal rühren Vanilleextrakt kommt
auch gleich mit rein es ging jetzt alles
super schnell los aber wir machen halt
einen richtig schnellen blitzapfelkuchen
vom Blech der total saftig ist und ihr
braucht keine Maschine dafür machis
Apfelkuchen
jawoll Apfelkuchen Karamellsoße mein
Geheimtipp müsst ihr nicht machen ich
persönlich find es richtig geil so und
eine Prise Salz warum hams hebt den
süßen Geschmack ganz genau zack reicht
und und weil nussr das mal gemacht hat
nussr so und da kommen jetzt eigentlich
ach so Zucker könnt ihr jetzt auch schon
mit dazu geben und B noch bisschen
Zucker gewesen ja so ein bisschen Zucker
und dann habe ich jetzt nur noch mehl
und Backpulver und ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher dass die meisten Leute die
Zutaten schon zu Hause haben und
eigentlich jetzt direkt loslegen K musst
du das nicht noch so 7 nee muss man
nicht bei dem röhrteig muss das nicht
sein weil das unnötig ist weil die
mehlnester werden von alleine
verschwinden weil das emer ein Rührteig
ist und wir hier nichts fluffig
aufschlagen und der Ofen ist schon
vorgeheizt genau der Ofen hat gerade
gepiept der ist schon vorgeheizt auf
180° Ober und Unterhitze ich merke
gerade du nutzt mich gerade n aus zum
Rühren Alter ich mach do gar nichts hier
ich rüre doch nur die aber das warte mal
wir haben jetzt nicht einmal gecutet wie
viele Sekunden waren das jetzt minut 2
Minuten 15 ja 2 Minuten also z Z Minuten
Kuchen jetzt werden eigentlich nur noch
die Äpfel geschält und geraspelt und
dann wird alles verereil und dann kommst
in den Backofen und wieso hast jetzt
keine Mixer ren können hier weil du
jetzt schon fertig bist das reicht schon
ich bin eine Maschine ne nur so lange
rühren bis es notwendig ist nicht überen
ach so warum denn das unnötig ach sorry
e sag einfach
DANKE DANKE perfekt ja ne schöner Teig
kannst du machen ach ne ist ein roh
drinne okay den Rest mache ich das
reicht du h ausg ich schwöre warum ach
du willst dass ich schäle weil du weißt
schange brauchst schälen das stimmt du
brauchst echt unnormal lange zum schäen
danke für deine Hilfe es war schön mit
Dir als mein Partner und mein Mann und
mein langjähriger weggefärte zusammen zu
backen aber ich habe eine Frage du hast
h so ein Backblech gelocht das Backblech
das ist ein Löcher wenn ein Teig rein
maachst dann ist vorbei ja das ist dann
vorbei deswegen machen wir jetzt ein
Backpapier unten runter ich ma mal Platz
damit Jasmin das auch schon mitfilmen
kann den backramm stellt ihr am besten
auf die kleinste Größe an das sind bei
mir 25 x 18 cm ich guck jetzt ob du
alles richtig machst ja und der Teig ihr
seht ja der Teig ist schon recht flüssig
das sieht man ja eigentlich ganz gut und
daher am besten noch mal die Ränder so
ein bisschen einschlagen wollte ich
gerade auch sagen so dann einfach immer
nur zum Rand hin knitten bis ihr einmal
angekommen seid und den Teig fülle ich
aber noch nicht ein ich kümmere mich
erst um die Äpfel und dann fülle ich
erst
[Musik]
ein so den Rest bekomme ich jetzt auch
alleine hin ohne hamser aber es ist
wirklich ein Blitzrezept also wenn ihr
mal spontan Besuch bekommt oder keine
Zeit habt dann speichert euch dieses
Rezept gerne ab aber ich habe auch das
Gefühl ich habe so viele apfelrezepte
mittlerweile da habt ihr wirklich die
Qual der Wahl wir hinterlassen euch mal
den Link zur Playlist in der Infobox und
ich fülle jetzt hier einfach den Teig
ein und darauf gebe ich dann die Äpfel
ihr könnt zu den Äpfeln jetzt auch noch
Zimt geben Zucker darauf verzichte ich
jetzt weil ich habe jetzt im Teig schon
Zucker und das reicht mir jetzt von der
Süße her aber Zimt könntet ihr jetzt
noch dazu geben aber ich möchte jetzt
den karamelligen Geschmack gerne im
Fokus haben daher jetzt da drauf und
dann wird das Ganze gebacken der Ofen
ist ja schon vorgeheizt auf 180° Ober
und Unterhitze und die Backzeit blende
ich euch dann ein
[Musik]
50 Minuten war der Kuchen jetzt im Ofen
und ich habe noch oben aprikotiert also
einfach Aprikosenmarmelade kurz erwärmen
und dann
bepinseln ja das gibt's wirklich das
glänzt dann schön und es gibt auch noch
mal ein bisschen fruchtigen Geschmack
das mach man noch Croissant beim
Croissant ja stimmt K richtig aber schon
OS ne das sind schon oschis muss ich
sagen aber super super saftig ne ich bra
gab achentschuldigung ich weiß Arab und
so ja okay ich muss nicht mehr mit Hand
essen hier bit schön ach so du goldene
Gabel ne
typisch so ne alles musst du falsch
verstehen also das sind wirklich super
super saftige Schnitten also die sind
extrem saftig Hand so ja guck mal du
kannst auch mal so also das man merkt
einfach wie saftig das ist Sahne würde
dazu auch ganz gut passen aber ich
wollte das einfach pur
genießen
boah voll aromatisch voll ich bin so
froh dass ich oben noch
aprikosenkonfettüre drauf gegeben habe
also schmeckt richtig lecker es schmeckt
einfach so man hat so ein heimeliges
wohliges Gefühl das ist so wie wie von
Oma einfach ne ist so das ist ja
typische Apfelkuchen von Oma obwohl ich
keine Oma hatte die Apfelkuchen gebacken
was hat den deine Oma immer gemacht
meine Mutter meine Mutter meine Oma hat
herzhaft gekocht ja aber die hat auch
mal was S ich weiß nicht hab nie so ja
ja okay deine Oma hat den gelebt ich
also ich habe nicht viel meine Oma
gehabt leider also wenn ihr noch eine
Oma habt dann schätzt es ich habe auch
leider ke dafür bringst du mir die
deutsche om nach Hause ja also das gibt
mir so wirklich richtige es ist Herbst
Sonntag draußen regnet drin ist es
kuschelig und dann hast du so ein Kuchen
dannmer so die Decke zu sich ja und dann
ist du das auf verkau mach so eine Kerze
an ne ja ja das macht auf jeden Fall aus
nein das gibt ein wirklich so richtig
gute Vibes dieser Kuchen und e der war
so schnell gemacht du warst ja dabei ich
find auch nicht so ich ich find das
gerade ich liebe solche Kuchen ja ichbe
sol Ken die bisschen höer sind so
bisschen mehr Teig ich meine auch wenn
ihr den jetzt flacher gemacht hättet
dann wäre der auch wahrscheinlich nicht
so saftig gewesen dann wäre noch mehr
durchgebacken klar da würde man die
Backzeit verringern aber der wäre nicht
so saftig gewesen und ich muss sagen ich
habe das jetzt in sechs sehr große
Stücke geschinten ihr könnt das auch
durch acht Teilen dann habt ihr acht
Personen damit satt gemacht ja dann
würde ich mal sagen Leute macht's
unbedingt nach unbedingt und es hat mich
jetzt so ein bisschen an unseren Podcast
erinnert wir haben ja auch ein Podcast
jetzt zusammen den Tuesday Talk jeden
Dienstag eine neue Folge also wenn ihr
noch mehr von uns beiden sehen möchtet
oder hören möchtet besser gesagt cool
Podcast Ken ja ne das eklig dann mit dem
Mikrofon lieber nicht also ich gönne mir
jetzt noch und wünsche euch viel Spaß im
nachmachen ciao
[Musik]
ciao